so from the start of the pandemic we've
heard the very general statement from a
bunch of different people who may or may
not know what they're talking about when
it warms up the virus is going to go
away and that suggests this kind of
seasonality to the virus and it implies
the virus can't survive in warmer
weather and we don't actually have
evidence of that at this point and it
appears to be sort of too simplistic of
a hypothesis but we do now have a very
good paper that's looking at the issue
of temperature and it has found that
there appears to be a temperature and
humidity combination present in the
places that have become sort of centers
of infection and spread the paper is
called temperature humidity and latitude
analysis to predict potential spread and
seasonality for kovat 19 it's a mouthful
but essentially what they did is they
looked at the cities that had large
amounts of communities spread and the
disease getting established and they
looked at the climate data from those
cities to see is there a pattern where
the virus is taking hold versus where
the virus is not and indeed check out
what they found they found that there
was significant community spread in
cities and regions along a narrow
east-west distribution roughly along the
30 to 50 degree North corridor at
similar weather patterns consisting of
average temperatures of 5 to 11 degrees
Celsius combined with low specific and
absolute humidity going on to say
there's been a lack of significant
community establishment in expected
locations based only on population
proximity and extensive population
interaction through travel so it's not
just the temperature the temperature
seems to be 5 to 11 C which is 41 to 52
Fahrenheit but also specific humidity
ranges and in fact places where you
would expect the virus to become
established based on proximity and
travel it has not when the temperature
and humidity haven't matched up with
these parameters so this tells us a few
different things this tells us there may
be a seasonal component here but it's
more complex than just temperature its
temperature and humidity
we conceivably could predict knowing
what the temperature and humidity ranges
tend to be as we get into spring and
fall we could predict where over the
coming months we might see more and less
spread on this basis and this is one of
the first more plausible explanations
more specifically of why it got so bad
in wuhan Italy Iran South Korea and and
some specific other places Seattle as
another example again these are
correlations we don't yet have a causal
link this is just one study but this is
also important to be considering now
also important is the understanding that
a lot of the United States may enter
those ranges as we get into spring and
summer so you have what the entire
climate and temperature thing there's a
few different elements to it on one hand
there's the question of whether the
virus itself can survive as the
temperature goes up so sometimes when
people say well when it gets warmer the
virus is going to start to die out or
it's going to last less that's a
question mark we don't know that to be
the case when we think of the flu it is
true that in places like the northeast
of the US where I live the flu epidemics
are tend to go away when it gets warm
but if you look at places that are warm
year-round they also still have flu
transmission the flu seems to adapt to
the warmer temperatures in those areas
so the question of whether a kovat 19
and the bug that the virus that causes
it can survive in warmer temperatures
that's one question when it gets warmer
people also tend to be outside more and
more spread out on average than inside
in office buildings and in close
proximity the thing that's another
factor but if we're self isolating
socially distancing and working from
home does that make a difference but
then lastly is this new issue of the
actual temperature and humidity ranges
at which the virus is more transmissible
more easily being transmitted the bad
news about this study
even though it shows a possible season
seasonal component is that a lot of that
belt is going to be including much of
the United States with that optimal
criteria so the odds that it simply goes
away when we get into spring and summer
on the basis of temperature and humidity
without additional intervention like
social distancing finding treatments etc
is very very low we're going to have to
keep doing of exhibiting behaviors that
for a lot of us aren't fun but it's just
going to have to happen there's no way
around it one of our sponsors today is
VIN Chara watches giving you 15% off
your entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch don't pay
thousands of dollars for a high-quality
watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of in
Cera's watches are made with high-end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but ever even chera watch
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether
and silver and white really nice elegant
look it's a coronagraph style wore it to
a gala over the weekend and a lot of
people ask me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really liked it as well as well as
the athletic strap it's a new year it's
a new decade it's time to re-establish
your style add something new to your
look and a high-quality watch is the
perfect way to do that you can get 15%
off inch arrows entire collection when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch